please welcome the multitalented kristin
chenoweth
[Applause]
[Applause]
i mean literally i assumed that we
would be very good friends no me too
because you have this enthusiasm and i
do too
you're kidding i know right we're this
we are very similar and i did make a
fool of myself do you know i don't i
would wake a fool of myself every day
what was your circumstance
okay so i had won a tony and on my way
up to getting the award drew was sitting
like where you are ma'am and so i'm
walking up
this is so funny i'm walking on the
phone oh my god
and she you'll never remember this
because it was great gardens here when
you're out for grey gardens and she's
flipping around like surely she's not
talking to me
i probably was
i was so like i can't believe it and
then i got a migraine and had to leave
the show but can you believe that i
never got to meet you that night we all
miss
cues sometimes but okay you just got
engaged yes
he is a country music guitarist and he
was at my niece's wedding he played at
an event at ou and she said i want their
band and i went to that wedding and of
course i was at the kids table by myself
because i'm always the single one
and um
he said i want to court you and i said i
don't have time i'm very busy i've been
run away by twice i don't i don't i
don't date good luck um you'll never see
me you know i did my all my excuses and
he never stopped and
oh my god you guys met at a wedding my
niece's wedding this is out of a movie i
know write it this is what everybody
goes to a wedding thinking might happen
to them and i love that you were like no
no no no no no no
and i didn't was like yeah
because i had been to the barbecue rodeo
and picnic
and you know
i just didn't i wouldn't say i didn't
believe in love anymore i just didn't
feel oh i need to get married that's not
something that is going to complete me
but when you do find a person that does
match you it is wonderful your fiance is
14 years younger than you and i
sometimes like if i go on the dating app
i'm on and i peruse every once in a
while i will ask people out if they're a
certain age am i wrong do you think i
thought in my wildest dreams a 13 years
younger man for me no i did not i was
always the young one in my relationship
why shut yourself off there are no more
rules who knows love doesn't have an age
true love does not have an age age never
matters to me and yet i'm kind of an
ageist when it comes to dating and i was
too until
now okay now it's christmas
yes you have a christmas album thank you
for
changing the course of our holidays 2021
and here on out for many years to come
um i was wondering
if you would do an improv singing game
with me
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like you and me would like make
the best pillow fighters ever like we
would just have so much fun like coco
and socks and pillow fighting and like
cozying up to movies and like
i see a montage in my head
okay so i'm gonna give you a christmas
topic and you'll sing about it uh to a
tune of a popular christmas song yeah
okay first step it's fruit cake to the
tune of oh christmas tree
okay
[Music]
oh fruitcake
why do you make me feel so bad oh fruit
cake oh food cake and also what do you
give me get
i never want to hear a christmas tree
again
and you're right fruitcake is
weird i don't like it this one's good a
re-gifted scented candle
to deck the halls
we gift your scented candles no matter
what the smell is if it is vanilla keep
it but if it smells like don't
[Applause]
and you know that will be on goop
i got the candle from goop and actually
it does smell beautiful kristen
chenoweth i have waited
um to get to know you
i admire you endlessly you really are a
testament to someone who comes on the
scene and just changes the world and
everybody falls in love with you and so
many iterations of all the things you do
get your holiday spirits on with your
copy of happiness is christmas and catch
kristen in national champions in
theaters friday december 10th pillow
[Applause]
[Music]
you